-Our next guest
is an Emmy-Nominated actor
who you know
from "Saturday Night Live."
She is making her New York
stage debut in the play,
"The Search for Signs
of Intelligent Life
in the Universe,"
which is running now through
February 6th at The Shed.
Everyone, please welcome
Cecily Strong!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, bud!
-Hi.
Hi, Jimmy.
-Cecily, welcome back
to the show.
It's so great to see you.
-Oh, thank you.
Love being back virtual.
-I know, but I guess
you have to be extra,
extra, extra careful.
-Yes, I'm living a very
monastic lifestyle right now.
-Yeah.
-A fantastic monastic lifestyle.
I loved you on "Saturday Night
Live," obviously,
and I've been lucky enough
to work with you, too,
but this is kind of
an insane thing.
You get to play --
-Oh.
-How many characters
do you play in this?
-I think I play 11
at my last count, but I'm --
There's other characters
that I'm talking to
that I'm not playing,
but, yes, it's --
-Wow.
-It's pretty nuts.
I feel like I've gone
a little bit nuts.
I think even somehow in a mask,
I can still --
people still know I'm talking
to myself, walking around.
-Just practicing your lines?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How does --
-And I was surprised
that I was getting looks
even with the mask.
I guess you can --
-How does it compare to "SNL"?
-Oh, it's -- you know,
it's very different.
Just, number one, we don't
have cue cards, it turns out.
-Oh, wow. They don't do that?
-They make you memorize...
-What?
-...other places.
-They don't have cue cards?
-I thought that was in my
contract, but...
-I heard that it was
Jeanine Pirro --
When you played Jeanine Pirro
very funny
on "Saturday Night Live,"
that kind of got you this role.
Is that true?
-Yeah, she insisted.
Wouldn't that be funny
if Jeanine actually did?
No, our director actually saw
the finale from last season,
and I guess, you know,
she saw me walking --
getting into a box of wine,
and she went like,
"That person's crazy enough
to take this on."
-[ Laughs ] The original --
The original show
starred Lily Tomlin and
Jane Wagner, who's the writer.
-Yes.
-They're producing this?
They're executive producers
on this?
-Yes, they are,
and they're in L.A.,
so I've only gotten to
really talk with them
on the phone and Zoom with them,
and we did a "New York Times"
article, and after --
I think we got about an hour
with them and David afterwards,
Leigh -- my director --
and I turned to each other
and sobbed just 'cause
it was so --
it's just amazing
that they're trusting us
and they're just
so funny in person.
And then this is very telling --
Jane's story.
But they were -- you know,
they were like,
"Yeah, call us on opening."
So right after the show,
Lee and I
have the phone in our hand,
and we call, and Jane said "Hi,"
and we went, "Hi!"
And then she went,
"Who is this?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good bit.
-Yeah.
If it was a bit.
We'll never know.
-Is there any way
to set this up?
-It's a --
We're redoing Lily's show,
but really, it's kind of --
it's exploring human connection,
basically, you know,
at a time when we haven't
really gotten to have it
and especially after theaters
have really been
shut down for two years.
It's also part of the show.
It celebrates being in the
theater together in this moment,
and it's been so special
every night.
It's such a surprising show
and, you know, some people
are laughing at the same time
some people are crying,
and it's a very surreal,
lovely experience.
-I was going to ask you --
-And I have, you know,
an umbrella hat on my head.
-Yeah.
I mean is it tough for you to --
You studied theater, I mean,
before you got into comedy.
-Yes, I'm a -- I studied it.
I'm a very serious thespian.
You know,
I think I missed a step.
I should have done, like,
a regular ensemble play.
I went -- I jumped back in
at a one-woman show
playing 11 characters.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
That's the way to do it, see?
Don't do anything easy, buddy.
Just go in and just crush it.
-No, no, no, yeah, you've got
to show people you're nuts.
-Yeah.
-Or you are, not your nuts.
I guess you could --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, don't show -- Thank you.
-Don't show people your nuts...
-No.
-...unless they've invited you.
-Don't show -- Yeah.
You are -- Yeah.
Can you believe, Cecily,
that you've been doing "SNL"
for 10 seasons?
-No, I mean,
it feels like 30 years sometimes
and then --
but it's always surprising.
I mean, the past two years,
it's been so up in the air.
So I'm still -- it still feels
new and fresh and --
-You're crushing it.
-I'm still learning,
and the only thing
I think I have down
is cue cards, sort of.
-Yeah, I know.
You're really --
You actually are very good
at cue cards.
-Yeah, I mean I should be
using cue cards in the show,
but I don't know, artistic
decision of the director.
-I heard that your mom and dad
were at your "SNL" audition,
is that true?
-Yes, my dad and my stepmom
were there
at iO, at the showcase,
and they were sitting
in front of Lorne,
but they were --
they knew he was there
and so they were so nervous.
I saw them after, and they
looked -- they were so pale.
It's like they'd seen a ghost,
and it was like,
"Wow, was I -- was it that bad?
You could have --
you could have laughed."
But then I realized
it was better that --
there was, like, another girl
there who was clearly, you know,
trying to help out her friend
that was auditioning.
It was, like, she was in some
polka dot dress or something,
like [Laughs]
really laughing so hard.
-Laughing at every other bit,
yeah.
-It was like --
Yeah, one of those, you know,
like those theater shows
where the audience --
the audience is in the play,
whatever it is.
-Yeah. When did you realize
that you were --
that comedy was your thing?
-You know, I was always making
my family laugh, at least.
You know, one of my first --
I had two really great
impressions since a little kid,
and one was the shrunken head
man from "Beetlejuice,"
and then I also liked the alien
that popped out of the guy's
stomach in "Spaceballs."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I should have done them
for my "SNL" audition.
-Yeah, you really should have
done that one.
Oh, my gosh, yeah.
I think things are going
pretty well
the way they are right now,
buddy.
Cecily, I love
having you on the show.
I can't wait to see you
on stage,
but also in person
here back at the show.
Congrats on all of this.
I appreciate you coming on.
-Soon enough. Thanks, Jimmy.
-Cecily Strong, everybody.
-Thank you.
-See her in "The Search
for Signs of Intelligent Life
in the Universe,"
running now through February 6th
at The Shed.